very quickly uh where's karen oliver oh
there's karen oliver
now karen do you have a picture of you
as a schooly girl
oh there there you
if are performs out of music in a
dungeon
what the hell are you wearing
it's like a pvc pinafore
we've got a warm
you used to hang around at a garage is
that the garages and the flats yeah
and would do what you do would you line
up well we there's kind of three guys
that we were stalking i guess
we played a game which was like a kiss
chase and the girls ended up in the
garages and the boys had to chase us
and while we were there the boys came in
and decided who they were going to have
so just kidding
it's good you're not going
back to britain are you you're like what
the hell it's just kissing it's a
kissing game just kissing
it was kind of very dark and i just
waited with my eyes kind of half closed
and ricky andrews came to me the hunk
i got him
and did you kind of hang around the
garage was that game go on for a long
time
um just a little bit but they got
condemned from
with asbestos and got pulled
glamorous down
the kiss chase we just went to the
garages and waited
sorry at chase is it it's just like
we'll wait here they'll come
karen in honor of zach's film 17 again
we thought we'd
take you on a trip back to teenage years
so if you look over there right
there's a picture of a garage right
so if you want to go over to the garage
with me come on oh we go here we go come
on
[Applause]
so now all we need now is a lineup of
girls
beside you oh
[Applause]
now just to recreate the the dank dark
atmosphere of that
asbestos-filled garage and harrow it
just
yields grammar and romance you just put
on this blindfold
okay lovely you ready okay you stand
there
okay yeah can you see anything no
no you can't now how many years has it
been since you
last kissed ricky andrews in that
carriage oh my god
[Music]
back then he was the best looking guy in
town
i happen to know he is now a glazier in
north london
[Applause]
do you remember how that kiss fell
kylo yes
[Applause]
do you recognize these lips
there you go
is it a secret of like focusing on
something first of all you have to pick
a point space
um so that you don't come off cross-eyed
normally the errors get made in the guys
and the nerds and the computer i say
that with the faction
make sure that um they can you know put
something in front of your face later on
so you don't come off crosstalk but
we thought we'd see how how good you
were reacting things that weren't there
because we've got some are you testing
you
yeah fans of yours have dressed as some
of your most
fearsome opponents okay all right so
they're are not here they're on green
screen but they are going to magically
appear in front of you
now we've got uh if children are
watching
uh perhaps this is a bit too frightening
it's just that we've gone for um
one of the dinosaurs from journey to the
center of the earth in 3d
and this is uh danielle may so as i say
i'm sorry if little children are
watching but hopefully they're not but
they might be frightened by this
here's danielle now
[Applause]
look at you go no
it looks like barney looks like barney's
had liposuction
[Applause]
do a bit of roaring for god's sake woman
oh
one more it is i think you'll probably
your greatest nemesis of all
uh it's uh phil craig from morkum who's
a bus ticket inspector
here he comes oh god
no not me no no no
save yourself yourself go
go
see that's why
i don't ride that bus
that's why that's why you had to tell
your emu story
we spent a lot of money on that costume
okay
it was going to be seen because zach
when you kind of made it big with scrubs
and
proper cash was coming in right you went
a bit car crazy dude
well i was the kid with the car pictures
on on my wall the po i always loved cars
and so the first thing i
i did when i had made a little cash was
get a beautiful porsche that i had
always uh
dreamed of and uh the car was brand new
and my friend
who played donald faison who played turk
on the show scrubs thought it would be
funny to play a practical joke on me
and um there's a show called punk do you
have punk teeth we did
yeah yeah well they got me really
horribly bad they they
it's the things like three days off the
lot and i i was going to a liquor store
with him it was all set up hidden
cameras
i didn't know obviously and some
teenagers asked us to buy them booze
because you know you can't drink to your
21 in the states and and i was like no
we're not going to
buy you booze i'm not going to be
responsible for you guys getting
hammered and
when we came out of the liquor store the
brand new car
appeared from my perspective to be
completely covered with graffiti and the
kids were just finishing doing it
like ruined and the whole thing had been
choreographed
with the hidden cameras and such that
that i wouldn't be able to catch the
[Laughter]
little
[Applause]
and i couldn't see from my perspective
because my adrenaline was so pumping
that he looks up and he's like a little
boy
and i stopped because i didn't realize
he was so young and um of course
they edited that whole bit out because
they don't really want you beating up
children
no they got me they got me really bad
really bad
so listen a funny one funny one more
thing about that story is that we went
into the uh when we went
into the the liquor store that my
co-star uh who played the turk donald
faison he
he knew he was on camera because he was
the guy on the joke and we walk in the
liquor store there's a giant rack of
porn it's the first thing you see when
you walk in
and i walk in i'm with my buddy and i'm
like i'm like magazines dvds
uh both probably okay give me the
address
i just put a picture in my mind stay
with us
and and so i walk over to the rack
because i'm like
wow look at all look at this check out
this girl and my friend who knows he's
on hidden camera he's like
oh man you know i'm not into that
i'm thinking like yes you are
and now you look very nice but i thought
you know you're a scot i thought you
might be sporting you know the kilt on
the red carpet
no no do you ever do the kilt oh yeah
i've done the kill i've done the
carpet not in the red carpet no i don't
think you should do it
yeah maybe i should i love people are
going yes you have
in glasgow oh i did
hey do you want to answer these
questions for me by the way this this
lady here
i mean basically did you move to america
she's from scotland
but it just goes wherever wherever i go
[Applause]
it's better than i do so if i'm saying
anything wrong you
you keep me in line apparently she will
yeah
minutes into the show yes you have
so maybe i i wore a a kilt at my
sister's wedding though in in
in paisley scotland and i had to go up
and do a reading
and my mother and the family were in the
front row and of course as you know in
scotland there's a certain rule to
wearing the kilts and you know i'm
sitting like this and then
everybody's kneeling forward you know
and my mom is
is looking at me she's doing this and
she's going
i think she's telling me to pray
the whole congregation is watching me so
i'm like listen i'm looking out and i'm
like
and i go like this
he's like then i realized that
everybody is staring right
and
and that's why i always forget that i've
worn kills
it's always a disaster now uh jared i
think i've done very well to hold off
till now
let's talk about your body because
is that you now is that you surfing now
no i don't know where that is actually
all right
is that a kill we know where it is oh
yeah hawaii
hawaii seriously seriously yeah is this
serious
[Applause]
wow you were there you probably took
so is it why but jared butler you have
your own
jared butler conventions
and i think we're seeing who's behind
them
more than a lucky guess
so no so these are real apparently so
yeah
um yeah they've had them in glasgow
they've had them in
vegas and it's vegas the one that we
belong to
right right so what's your name lady
moira
moira how many people go uh
about a hundred
[Applause]
you could have talked it up a bit
we weren't going to do a head count we
weren't going to check
you could have gone with 500.
three oh very good
this isn't live there's still time to
change
well next time we'll all go it'll be
[Music]
great